cloud computing services are
transforming how businesses and
government agencies use technology
cloud services are not available to
satisfy almost any id requirement
although cloud computing services vary
greatly
they all have some basic qualities and
benefits in common
and they can be classified into a few
basic cloud service kinds
hello everyone i'm sharmly and i welcome
you all to this new video of simply
learn
on cloud computing services
let me give you an overview of the
concepts you are going to go through in
this video
first we will go through what is cloud
computing
then we will have an introduction to
cloud computing services
followed by the types of cloud computing
services
and at the end we will look into the
features and benefits of cloud computing
services
so let's not waste any more time and get
started with the video
so what is cloud computing
cloud computing is the distribution of
cloud computing services
by the internet including servers
storage databases networking software
analytics
intelligence to provide faster
innovation more flexible resources and
economies of scale
you usually only pay for the cloud
services you use which helps you cut
cost run your infrastructure more
efficiently and scale as your business
grows
now that we know what cloud computing is
let's proceed with understanding
cloud computing services
cloud computing services provide users
with a variety of capabilities including
email storage backup data retrieval app
creation testing data analysis audio
video streaming
software on demand regardless of the
type of service
although cloud computing is still a
relatively new technology it is now
being used by a wide range of
organizations including large
enterprises small businesses non-profit
government agencies and even individual
consumers
so not all clouds are created equal and
not every sort of cloud computing is
appropriate for every situation a
variety of models varieties and services
have evolved to assist you find the best
option for your needs
to begin one must decide on the type of
cloud deployment or cloud computing
architecture that will be used to
implement your cloud services
cloud services can be deployed in three
different ways public cloud private
cloud or hybrid cloud
now let's dive down deeper into cloud
computing services and explore its type
in more detail
cloud computing unlike a microprocessor
is not a single piece of technology
rather it's a system made up of three
services
infrastructure as a service
platform as a service
and software as a service
so let's have a better understanding of
each
starting with infrastructure as a
service
so what is infrastructure as a service
it is a type of cloud computing that
uses the internet to provide virtualized
computing resources
the cloud provider controls id
infrastructures such as storage server
and networking resources
and also offers them to subscribe
companies via virtual machines
accessible over the internet in ias
model
for businesses it can provide numerous
advantages including the ability to make
tasks faster easier more flexible and
less expensive
now let's have a look at the working of
iaas
users connect to resources and services
across a wide area network such as the
internet and then use the cloud provider
services to complete the application
stack the user can for example log into
the infrastructure as a service platform
to build virtual machines
install operating systems in each vm
deploy middleware such as databases
create storage buckets for workloads and
backups
and install the enterprise workload onto
that virtual machine
customers can then track cost monitor
performance balance network traffic
solve application difficulties and
manage disaster recovery using the
provider's service
so moving ahead let's go through its
advantages and disadvantages
advantages
organizations select
infrastructure as a service because
operating a workload without having to
buy manage
and support the underlying
infrastructure is frequently easier
faster and more cost effective a company
can rent or lease infrastructure from
another company using infrastructure as
a service
for workloads that are transitory
experimental or change abruptly
it is an effective cloud service
paradigm
for example if a company is creating a
new software product
hiring an ieas provider
to host and test the application may be
more cost effective
once the new software has been
thoroughly tested and refined the
company can move it away from the
iaas environment
and into a more traditional in-house
deployment
if the expenses of a long-term
commitment are lower
the organization could commit peace or
software to a long-term
iaas deployment
now disadvantages
billing can be a challenge for some
firms despite its flexible pay as you go
model cloud invoicing is quite detailed
and it is broken down to reflect
specific service usage
when evaluating the invoices for each
resource
and service involved in application
deployment users frequently experience
sticker shock or discover expenses that
are greater than expected
another issue
it face is lack of insight
because its providers own the
infrastructure the configuration and
performance of that infrastructure are
rarely transparent
to its consumers
users may find it more difficult to
operate and monitor systems due to the
lack of transparency
users of infrastructure as a service are
also concerned about service
availability and reliability
the supplier has a big influence on the
workload's availability and performance
the workloads of users will be impacted
if a provider has network constraint or
any other type of internal or external
outage
furthermore because it is a multi-tenant
design the problem of noisy neighbors
might have an adverse effect on users
workloads
so now these are the top infrastructure
as a service providers
linode is a privately held cloud hosting
firm based in the united states that
offers virtual private
servers host wins web hosting cloud
hosting and dedicated server options are
all available from host wins
microsoft azure is a cloud computing
service operated by microsoft for
application
management via microsoft manage data
centers
digitalocean
offers developers cloud service
that make it easy to deploy and grow
programs that run on several machines at
the same
time alibaba cloud is a cloud computing
firm that serves online businesses as
well as alibaba's own e-commerce
ecosystem
so the second service is platform as a
service
what is platform as a service
platform as a service products which are
geared towards software development
teams include computing and storage
infrastructure as well as development
platform layer that includes web servers
database management systems and software
development kits for multiple
programming languages
working off platform as a service
for software development
it does not replace an organization's
complete ip infrastructure
it's made possible by the hosted
infrastructure of a cloud service
provider
a web browser is the most common way for
users to access the offsettings
platform as a service such as
application hosting and java development
can be supplied by a public private or
hybrid clouds
so
now let's look into the advantages and
disadvantages
advantages
the main advantage of platform as a
service for users is its simplicity and
convenience
much of the infrastructure and other id
services will be provided by the
platform as a service provider
which users can access from anywhere
wire or web browser
the flexibility to pay on a per use
basis allows businesses to forego the
capital costs associated with
on-premises gear and software
many platform-as-a-service solutions are
aimed towards software developers
these platform provider computation and
storage infrastructures as well as text
editing version management compilation
and testing capabilities to assess
developers in swiftly and efficiently
developing your software
coming to the disadvantages
platform as a service on the other hand
can cause issues
with service availability and resilience
customers may suffer as a result of
of a service outage or other
infrastructure interruption
which might result in costly
productivity losses
it supplies on the other hand will
typically deliver
reasonably high up times
another widespread problem is when the
lock-in which occurs when users are
unable to simply transition many of
their services and data from one
platform as a service solution to
another
when choosing a provider users
must consider the business risk of
service outages and vendor login
internal changes to a platform as a
service product could also be a problem
the impact on users might be tough and
receptive
if a platform as a service provider
seizes supporting a programming language
or chooses to use a different set of
development tools
so let's have a look at the top platform
as a service provider
ibm cloud computing refers to a set of
cloud computing services for businesses
provided by ibm a technology corporation
red hat is a collection of tightly
integrated red hat technologies for
building cloud infrastructure and
developing cloud native apps on premises
elastic beanstalk aws elastic beanstalk
is an amazon web services application
deployment
orchestration solution
salesforce offers crm services as well
as enterprise applications for customer
service marketing
automation analytics and application
development
and software ag cloud is an open and
independent cloud platform that serves
as your one stop shop for all software
ag has to offer in the cloud
now coming to the next service which is
software as a service
so what is software as a service
customer relationship management or crm
marketing automation and business
analytics are just a few of the
application level services offered by
software as a service
companies
so how does it work
the provider gives consumers network
based access to a single copy of an
application that the provider design
expressly fought software as a service
distribution
in the software on demand model
the source code for the program is the
same for all clients and new features or
functionalities are rolled out to all
the users at the same time
the data of each model's customer may be
stored locally in the cloud or both
locally in the cloud depending on the
service level agreement
coming to its advantages
customers subscribe to a software as a
service solution rather than buying and
installing software or additional gear
to support it
many firms can now budget more
effectively and predictably by
converting cost to recurrent operating
expenses
you can also cancel software as a
service subscriptions at any time to
avoid incurring recurring fees
its systems are frequently customizable
and can be connected with other
corporate applications
particularly when using software for the
same vendor
vertical scalability is a feature of
cloud services
like software as a service which allows
clients to access more or fewer services
or features on demand
disadvantages of software as a service
when providers indoor
service delays impose undesirable
modifications to service offerings or
suffer a security breach
all of these things can have a
significant impact on customers
ability to use the software as a service
offering
customers should be aware of their
software as a service provider's sla and
ensure that it is followed
if the provider adopts a new version of
an application it will roll it out to
all of its clients
whether or not they want it
this may need the organization
allocating additional training time and
resources
switching vendors can be tough as it is
with any cloud service provider
customers must migrate massive volumes
of data when switching vendors
furthermore some vendors use
technologies and data types which can
make transferring client data between
cloud providers even more difficult
so coming to the top companies that
provide software as a service
adobe is a collection of adobe
incorporation programs and services that
provide user with access to software for
graphic design
video editing
web development and photography as well
as a set of mobile apps and certain
optional cloud services
sap is a platform as a service designed
by sap se for developing new application
and enhancing
existing ones in a secure cloud
computing environment managed by sap
google cloud google cloud platform is a
set of cloud computing services provided
by google that run on the same
infrastructure as google's internal
products such as google search gmail
drive and youtube
freshworks cloud platform allows users
to manage their identities and access
across all of their freshworks products
and atolation advanced features such as
a 99.9 uptime sla unlimited storage and
premium support provide teams the
confidence to scale reliably
now that we have all the in-depth
information about different types of
cloud computing services
let's move ahead and explore its
benefits and features which makes it so
popular and convenient
first the supplier hosts and maintains
the site in their own facility the cloud
hosting provider acquires hosts and
maintains the necessary hardware and
software
users avoid the construction
expenditures and maintenance problem
that would be incurred if the service
was established on-premise
second self-service using a web-based
interface
through a web interface service users
can initiate certain service functions
as well as increase or reduce
their service consumption level with
little or no intervention from the
service provider
third is you must pay to utilize the
facility
users of the service only pay for the
services they use when compared to the
typical method of building on-site id
capacities
targeted for the highest usage
situations and then having that capacity
to go unused for the most of the time
this can result in significant cost
savings
and the fourth one is scalability that
comes close to being infinite cloud
computing service providers usually have
the instruct infrastructure in place to
deliver their services at a large scale
that means that cloud service consumers
can readily accommodate business
expansion or periodic surges in service
usage
well this is all about cloud computing
services we have almost reached the end
of this video
if i missed anything important do let me
know in the comment section i hope you
enjoyed this video on cloud computing
services and learn something new from it
if you like this video then please do
hit the like button thanks for watching
this video and stay tuned for more
updates and videos from simply
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here